hello welcome back to games twice
coverage of e3 2015 and I'm joined by
Chris Miller from fun bits
hey bub its there somebody day three
yeah it's almost done almost my voice is
almost gone I've almost run into
t-shirts I'm gonna end big exactly long
we're gonna I'm strong and what a way to
end it's been six years since we saw the
princess it's been a while it's been
about four years four years yes it's
been a long time I remember playing the
first one a lot on PlayStation Network
and you guys are back a different take
on five princess this time it is it's
it's taking all the kind of chaos and
combat in the original classes and kind
of showing him in a new way where people
can actually play together one of the
big feedback we heard in the originals
people loved it they loved the
multiplier PvP but there's a lot more
people that want to just enjoy the
experience and drive it themselves at
their own pace and have a good time and
so this is kind of our leading focus
right now for that princess adventures
cool so [ __ ] princess Avengers a
four-player drop in drop out go up romp
drop in drop out and you can be online
or on the couch so it's great you can
just by yourself you can log in with
friends and play online or four people
on the couch and one of the things we've
done is you can choose a personality
type as well as a character class and
your personality type actually kind of
changes the script in the combat and the
banter as you play through so when
you've got four people playing together
they banter and talk amongst each other
and kind of drive the story with you
excellent
I played this back at the PlayStation
experience when you guys first announced
it I had a lot of fun and one of the
things I loved the most was I was a
collecting all the cake and it turning
into this massive mass version of
yourself so that's what they're doing
though it's just if you eat cake it
heals you if you keep eating cake and
you lots of cake then you go into chubby
mode and then you can really bring smack
down on the goblins and the enemies in
the game it's excellent and we've got to
have four of your friends playing off
screen here they're doing a wonderful
job and tell us about the classes and
how they sort of interact and and work
with each other so I've got the engineer
an engineer can disarm traps and bombs
and the mage is kind of your range class
he's a little bit squishy
he'll die pretty easily sort of hang
back you've got the archer and you've
also got the warrior so the worry was
kind of your tank could can run in there
and basically just kind of push the
enemies back he's got a shield bash
but also as you adventure through you
can like all kinds of gear and loot that
changes your character as well so the
type of play the type of weapons they
have changes up their actions it seemed
like you actually had a much higher
emphasis on loot than I was expecting
you're kind of changing weapons as
you're going through the level as well
yes we've got full customization of your
armor your hats your weapons Heights and
you can fully customize all your gear
and then say you want to actually like
the flame sword more than the ice sword
you can actually level it up and you can
take it to the upgrade guy and you'll
grade all your gear and loot as well
over time and your characters level up
as well so there's a much deeper system
there for finding and looting and
customizing your characters and if when
you're dropping into a four player map
for instance kind of like me and my
friend like can we both be the archer
can your four archers or do you have you
can do whatever you want and that's the
kind of cool thing you have to commit at
a checkpoint as what class you want and
you have to play that class until the
next checkpoint yeah so checkpoints the
kind of area where you can like okay
let's change up our strategy we can all
be warriors you can mix and match with
you know a different grouping and it's
kind of fun it's it's good way to kind
of enjoy all the classes in action RPG
because you know you can play other
games where you're like level 30 like oh
my god I gotta go all the way back to
the start of the game if I want to try a
different character class and that's
kind of the fast action of fat
princesses it's just jump in grab the
controller and just start having fun and
just experience all of it at once cool
so your four classes are kind of
leveling off individually and if you
were like to start the game then could
you like bring your level 15 archer in
or so you can jump in with other people
and they could it just based on you know
absolutely not
everyone gonna get their asses handed to
them but you can also you know select
and swap out your gear and one of the
cool things is - it's like there's
always a game there's not enough games
out there we can hand it to the other
half on the couch yeah and they can
actually be helpful and have a good time
and they have a joy playing so it's
we're really excited that we're allowed
to do it on four player co-op game
that's fun story driven so in case
you're trying to divide that line of
having an RPG game but also it's sort of
casual accessible you know sometimes you
want to log in and do a raid for four
hours and sometimes you want to play
something
they're just a story and replay some
dungeons and that's what we have here is
we have a good replay system where you
can actually go back in the dungeon
conditions change so you can actually
keep replaying and try flight or loot
and then we had tons of customizations
as well for all the characters as well
so on top of the classes you've got the
personality types you've got male and
female all kinds of really cool
customizations and unlockables to change
your character over time as well cool
I'm pretty sure this actually level I
played in Las Vegas I do this the first
part is the beach invasion and we also
have rescuing the princess from the
castle which is the next level we're
also showing here and we also have
zagged boss battle that we're showing at
the floor as well where you can try and
defeat the Zerg destroyer it's pretty
hard boss but it's using strategy with
the different classes and figuring out
how you can actually do damage to him
it's kind of a really kind of fun
experience I like it you see you've got
a beach invasion for your first level
it's like Call of Duty
I guess the other thing with games like
this is how much content is there so
like how many levels are we talking
about here what's a lot although there's
a long campaign if you're just certain
play through we're gonna a 68 hour
experience of just story base and then
from there you've got you know replaying
the dungeons but you're gonna go to all
kinds of locations we're gonna go to the
pirate caves salty mountains wash Lake
Black Forest by forcing the originals
you get to revisit that area as well
which is cool and we have the village
here on the docks and the beach was just
it's a huge game it's so much bigger I
think people are getting even anticipate
when they check it out you guys it must
be wonderful for you to be releasing
this game net at the PlayStation 4 is
such a nice healthy install base as well
are you guys gonna be bringing this out
on Vita at all but across what's a
determined we'd love to we'd love to
address the beta players and fun bits
was born out of beta with a skate plan
so you know that's kinda we have a love
for that device but for now it's PSN ps4
we have it later this year and it's
great that's it's not even a great part
in that and just really focus on
gameplay and fun and it's really great
to work with a partner that kind of lets
you explore and iterate and really
polish and make a really polished fun
experience so it's been great
cool I think we've talked a lot about
the nitty gritty because I was just so
interested while all this was playing so
let's focus on the gameplay a little bit
I just kind of give us an idea of what
exactly is going on here head of teams
working together so right there everyone
just got almost party white there and so
just standing next to another player you
can bring them back instantly or they'll
get work to a checkpoint if you don't
bring them back within a certain amount
of time we got somebody there in chubby
mode running around their other pants
they've been eating too much cake
they've just brought three guards to
find the guards keys and they're
bringing them back to get into the main
gate here so as they get to the guard
told you let's go in but the goblins are
still attacking you need to defend the
gate before you guys can go in and then
get to the princess is there some sort
of like yeah I see the like the chubby
mode is when you eat too much cake I bet
I remember seeing something like like an
overpowered mode where you were able to
like just stomp around and the awesome
meters purple meter there when that
pours up all the way and you go into
awesome mode you activate awesome sauce
it gives you a really good boost it's
kind of like a POW where you could do
more damage you can run a little faster
and you can beat the crap out of
gobbling other characters how could I
have forgotten the awesome sauce
otherwise but it things we did - is uh
you're always collecting gear and loot
and the party shares it which is cool so
the competitive aspect is collecting
gold versus the co-operative aspect is
collecting gear yeah so if you someone
gets the chest first they got a cool new
helmet or shield everyone gets it in the
party which is cool but there's gold
grab everyone's going for gold on their
own that's kind of their competitive
score for everybody because then you
could use that to upgrade your weapons
so is all but the gold is used for is
for a specific upgrading their weapons
upgrading buying stuff from store
vendors and just kind of showing that
you've got the most gold grabbed when
you get to a checkpoint first person to
get to the checkpoint guys checkpoint
champion and they get some gold as well
so it's kind of you get people racing to
the checkpoints - and we're trying to
put some competitive nature in this game
and it's gonna be evolving over time the
same like it working together to get XP
working - back together to get weapons
but just be selfish on the side well
cash grabbing on the side yeah that's
the best part of a co-op game it's
actually the part where you're not
playing cooperatively at all let's have
a little bit a little bit look more at
some of the gameplay here and is there a
boss fight coming up next - my
remembering correct it's a little while
they've got a SOG destroyer because it's
quite a ways off as a big demo for the
show hey how many how many bosses are in
the game uh I believe we got about five
major bosses
and we've got a handful of elites that
you'll be fighting as well along the way
but yeah the boss battles are fine
there's a good time it's a kind of
classic Mega Man style house battles
that we like everyone has their class
everyone has their role a kind of thing
and lastly how long you guys been
working on this it's been a while so
it's an interesting turn of face for the
series honestly it kind of seems like
you guys are making a game that we
haven't seen on the place a couple years
almost so after finished a skate plan we
roll directly into working on that
princess adventures and it's been good
it's been it's good to take the style of
the original and kind of bring it to the
PlayStation 4 you know kind of out the
framerate and add more effects and add
just more chaos in classes and more
characters than we've ever had before
and just give it a lot more depth in
terms of even the voice acting the
narrator was so classic to the original
and he's back so we have Nathan Tom Kane
and Nolan North is actually in the
really actually actually plays a chicken
on fire you gotta know the North he's
lying this fat sausage where we have a
really great past in this game it's
pretty fantastic next time you could get
him to voice the cake you just figured
out when I had somehow hit the first go
so yeah so Chris really from fun miss
thank you so much for coming on thank
you and when will we be able to play far
proceed but all you'll be able to play
that princess later this year later this
year I know this year so many games
coming out in 2015 we got one more to
look forward to and thanks very much
come on and thank you so much to your
wonderful eyes off camera for playing
and putting on a great show and we'll be
back here in the gamespot stage in just
a minute stay tuned